I don't necessarily think it's like over  for girls that have a high body count  because all right because I asked guys  this question all the time I say okay  would you prefer a girl with this many  body like a higher body count but she  hasn't slept with anyone you know  or I say would you rather a girl that  slept with two guys you know there's the  only other guy she slept with  you so so girls can get away with it  they just move right but like the issue  is it's internal because it hurts your  ability to pair bond and so you can't  connect with the guy you're supposed to  be with as much if you've been with like  guy after guy after guy after guy you're  exchanging Energies